Let's assume that the school also kept attendance per grade.
In this case, we've added a third column, grade, to our data.
So each row now represents for a given date and a given grade.
How many students attended school on that day.
Now if d3 or whichever library we're using, they implement some of
the principles of the grammar of graphics wasn't so flexible.
If we've added another column to our data and
it was tightly coupled to how we represented it.
We may have to redo a bunch of work we previously done to draw the same lines,
to draw the same axis's.
But in our case, and we'll see later when I go through some live code examples.
Adding another column, or in this case a categorical variable,
allows us to keep a lot of aesthetic and reapply that aesthetic.
In this case, three times.
One for each grade.
And if our data set had grade 12 in it,
we would have a separate line for 9th, 10th, and 11th grade.
Something interesting we see hear is that it appears 10th graders were not
affected by the flu.
While we have 9th and
11th graders with a severe dip in attendance during the later winter months.
10th graders, for whatever reason, have seemed to avoided the flu.
Due to the flexibility of the grammar of graphics, we were able to apply
the same aesthetic, in this case, a line, and the same axes to different data.
In this case, data that has a great column added and is categorized by day.
So instead of having to redo all the work of specifying how to draw a line.
And how it integrates with our data.
We simply split up our data by grade and draw in one line for each category.
In this case, the grade